un record du monde a été battu ce week
end à asbestos
à l'occasion du slac fest traversé la
plus longues sangles souple au monde
le tout à quelques 450 pieds sont
environ 130 mètres au dessus de la mine
jeffrey
sur la vingtaine de participants de
calibre international de ont réussi don
meehan blaine britanno colombienne il
faut tout simplement je dis simplement
il faut marcher d'un bout à l'autre sans
tomber bien sûr et sans prendre de pause
on encore cette idée que ça se passe sur
des fils de fer mais c'est plus du tout
le nom n'est pas sur la file de fass
vraiment sanglant voit ici là une sangle
moi je peux policiers l'ont dit caire
pour ce qu'ils appellent ça la flamme
mais c'est vraiment très minces
c'est un pouce dollars ne pas tomber
cela peut sembler facile lorsque les
lignes sont de courte distance mais cela
représente tout un défi sur une ligne de
2 km sans compter la hauteur
vertigineuse
même s'il a chuté à quelques reprises
ses participantes a parcouru la ligne en
3h13
ça devrait être centrée sur toi même
puis à calmer à l'intérieur a beaucoup
c'est très méditatif
un événement qui vise aussi à redonner
ses lettres de noblesse à l'ancienne
mine jeffrey que les gens voient note
beaupuy minier puis on veut on veut se
développer seul plus possible parce que
c'est vraiment magnifique
une certaine effervescence en l'air tous
les genres sont rassemblés pour voir
dany bouchard c'est l'un des
organisateurs de l'événement
ça fait deux heures qu'il est sur la
corde il est tombé quelques fois il est
fatigué mêlée à quelques pas d'arriver
aujourd'hui le principal défi je pense
que c'était la chaleur puis là je me
disais qu'ils savent à bien marquer les
franquistes gorgée d'eau que je freinais
longtemps tous les funambules
s'entendent pour dire que pour accomplir
un tel exploit
il faut rester bien ancrée dans le
moment présent autant que des fois je me
disais modique je fou comment ça c'est
que je me suis embarqué là-dedans
la seconde après je me dis modique genre
d'arrivée je me dis mais non tu es
tellement content d'être là enfin que
c'est comme un espèce de cycle qui se
passe en continu pendant deux heures
dans ma tête
filoche arrive ici je compte à m si
natacha lavigne radio-canada asbestos